hello they reject nation
I'm Greg Alba and I'm Jean Humphrey we
are going to watch the trailer for the
king's man
Matthew Vaughn returning for a prequel
this is exciting so I wanted to give a
shout out really quick to the folks
behind darkweb I'm gonna be hosting a
panel at Comic Con this Friday July 19th
at 1:30 p.m. at the hoarding Grand
Theatre it's the same day the dark web
series premieres on Amazon it's an 8
episode serialized anthology series has
a wide variety of cast members in there
for example you got Nicholas Brendon
Claire Kramer Lana McKissack Michael
nardelie who's been on this channel
before Naomi Gonzalez Simba and Elly you
Mambo I think I said that alright I'll
master it by this Friday so if you're at
SDCC this weekend make sure to come by
if you have Amazon Prime make sure to
check out this series there was an
independently funded series the trailer
you guys can go watch it online right
now we did a reaction to it as well it
looks fantastic
beside be part of this panel I'm excited
to check out this show they're gonna be
sponsoring a few videos over the next
two weeks
I'm excited be partnered up with them in
general any on to the movie
throughout time our people robbed live
and killed a fine until one day we found
ourselves noblemen arrest me but that
nobility never came from a thief or a it
came from being tough and ruthless
[Music]
the real power is not fun hands
and how they could be defeated
[Music]
ah sorry a Wonder Woman yeah
Wow whoa hey I know you want to fight
but there are other ways of doing your
duty mm-hmm
[Music]
fascinating yeah fascinating
well ileft lee looks different than the
first two Kingsman movies this looks a
lot more serious I'm sure it'll have
like some Matthew Vaughn humor infused
in here here Aaron taylor-johnson is in
this too what's hurting with his cast
lead I think he's gonna be a relative of
eggsy's because their characters have
the same last name exist Dean yeah
always meant to be chosen one prophecy
of the Kingsmen stitched into lapel
somewhere yeah like that he's able to
take a different aesthetic for this one
he's directed the first two this is like
his Transformers he's just gonna make
these movies fresh essentially I mean he
seems like he's very passionate about it
I know that he wants to launch a TV show
as well I do wonder how well this one
would do though I know that Kingsman the
Secret Service was a big hit the Golden
Circle from what I remember is that
people were saying that it didn't
perform as high as people had hoped it
would perform it seems like he really
wants to like bring this whole universe
to life it has its own comic book series
sort of it was like it's a comic book
but the comic books being written
alongside the movies yeah it doesn't
feel like a traditional adaptation yeah
exactly it's not one of those franchises
where the fans of the comic are so
invested and then they get the movie so
it's a little bit of a different
franchise I think the movie looks really
cool I have never really watched the
Kingsmen movies going yeah I've always
kind of like the mystique I don't think
like any of this would detract or
undermine any of the world-building
they've done because they do have a
really cool world I think part of what's
made the Kingsmen franchise so awesome
is the exploration of you go to burden
then you go to America this could be
awesome it looks like really intense
this one look a long war movie actually
yeah yeah yeah one if I recall the
original movie right they said you know
the Kingsmen was founded in World War
one so I like when movies like this go
back into historical periods like that
and especially with the potential that
leaves you first cheeky nods to like
know they were involved
than some kind of historical events
Wonder Woman vibes aside I just think
the aesthetic is really cool we don't
really go to World War one as much as a
lot of other periods in history I feel
like just as an aesthetic your note I
think that's exciting to me and to see
what they're gonna do with the history
cuz I guess the plot of this is they're
trying to stop World War one or
something akin to World War one because
it's all these leaders of the world who
want to start this massive war that
they're trying to go me and we have the
IMDB right here as a collection of
history's worst tyrants and criminal
masterminds gather to plot a war to wipe
out millions one manless race against
time to stop them inducted into the
Kingsmen they're gonna be like only you
for some reason can do this also they
get you know Djimon Honsou he's like the
secret you know comic book actor he's
just everywhere guardians of the galaxy
Captain Marvel Shazam now kings in the
next x-men movie let's get everything it
doesn't look like one of those prequels
where it's all about remember this one I
mean they're sure they have the nods
here of the mansion and how they brought
the tailor or store to life and whatever
it looks like it's really doing its own
thing I was a little taken aback by how
invested it was in this world war one
plotline got a little bit of vibes of
was that Benedict Cumberbatch movie an
intimidation game the imitation game I
got a little bit of those vibes as well
because this seems like it's gonna be
like a political thriller and I didn't
expect that going into this another
trailer would just be like a really cool
fun fast but you know Kingsman yeah
exactly and I didn't see any of that
like signature trademark action only
just like a little nugget of a few shots
but it was in such serious moments I'm
pretty surprised by this he helmed x-men
first class in some ways I get a little
bit of that vibe in terms of how X been
first class was marketed where that felt
a lot more serious and it's trailers and
the movie actually was and I'm sort of
wondering if that's what we're getting
here I got to feel like the attitude of
Kingsman will hold true
yeah there's a universe that it exists
and that has a personality that I don't
imagine going away although what does
excite me about a prequel like this make
part of them Kingdom in movies is crazy
gadgets and crazy technology and while
I'm sure they'll have a version of that
I'm always excited to see like what the
old-time version of that would be back
when things weren't is crazy I would say
an imitation game because this feels
more like a spy thriller yeah exactly as
opposed to you know like a Tinker Tailor
Soldier Spy and it feels more like that
and less of oh cool action movie even
though it doesn't look like it's doing
any of like the typical prequel stuff at
least with character why so you know I
couldn't tell if that one guy ray
Fiennes was like interacting with was
supposed to be Colin Firth mmm yeah
hairy but I don't think it is because
one is gonna be some tie-in baby boy
Harry shows up at the end in the movie
you know because it makes me wonder if
kind of like x-men first class but by
how old this is if it's gonna be a rogue
one situation worse just a one-off or
can they make their own franchise out of
this and upon this one you know because
I know they want to do like a Kingsman
three as yeah but you know is that be
confusing to like the titles just have a
slight different pronunciations man is
everything eggsy and king's man is all
these others yeah in history confusing
for audiences should it even make the
attempt to truly tie-in maybe that's
Michael Caine's character or like ties
into that a little bit more towards the
end or something you know I only hope
that the action isn't like crazier than
all the action we know will happen in
the future cuz that's the one thing that
drives me crazy about prequels is when
you watch something that's like way
before and somehow appears way more
sleek and it's yes and what you know is
in the future and they never think - is
this looks like a bit of an epic as much
as like a grounded spy thriller I really
like the music behind it - this looks
Baker and stakes in a more personal way
yeah World War one yeah I wonder if he
kind of feeling
he has to treat it a little bit with
some sensitivity honestly I think that
might be a cool thing to see just
because the Kingsmen movies have their
aesthetic a hundred percent especially
with a new cast of characters and a time
period to setting that is very real and
very tangible I would love to see them
kind of strike a different chord with
this group appeals you know one thing
this trailer didn't really give me
though that I kind of would have liked
because what they're teasing right here
is the story the exploration a little
bit of the plot the first two Kingsman
movies have such a big charismatic lead
with Colin Firth and Taron Egerton and
here's like you know really serious I
think I usually imagine I'm gonna be
yeah people seem pretty amped for that
guy from trust the young guy the young
dude who looks like he's the recruit
yeah we're pretty excited to see him get
a lead role like this but I think this
would have to kind of sell us on a lead
character too yeah because I don't know
how invested the fans the Kingston
franchise like yeah really I check out
the origins the Kingsmen yeah yeah
totally it's one of those things where
when I hear like Matthew Vaughn talk
about it who I think is an amazing
director I really like Golden Circle
actually it seems like there was a bit
of a split with audiences and critics on
how they ultimately felt about that film
I loved it just to see him at least you
know dipping his toe into the past with
a completely different kind of vibe is
very interesting to me I don't if you
want to keep the franchise alive I feel
like that's a smart way to go about it
yeah you know I'll mix it up try new
things of course of course alright guys
well thank you for watching
are you excited for the Kings Man and
make sure to leave a comment below you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell make sure
to watch the new episode series dark web
premieres Friday July 19th on Amazon and
before we wrap this up I would like to
give a patron of the day shout out to a
man named Kurt Anderson you know if I'm
going to talk about you I'm gonna talk
about two things one how sexy you are oh
yeah - how old you are
oh he's so Curt Anderson he seems like a
dude who could be timeless he could tell
me he's like 150 years old and that he's
fought in some great Wars
and he still looks as good as he does
because the guy can rock a sea I've
never seen him in a suit but you look at
him and you're like this guy can rock
this sooner
he's got that silver fox out of sekiz
kind of look what we know about Curt I
mean Curtis and no meg hurts a world
traveler so Kirk could easily be some
kind of high-grade espionage assassin
secret agent guy and maybe he just
doesn't tell us why he's in only
different places you know that is 99% of
the time of how I feel about him yeah
which makes me wonder why he
occasionally fluctuates with his pledge
because people I can't make such great
money you should meet like our top
pledge guy I don't know man sometimes
you're infiltrating like a crime ring or
something you got to buy your way in and
sometimes patreon pledge money you got a
dip in I would imagine anyway I'm not a
professional espionage artist but I
would assume that in Kurt's life comment
below Kurt let us know well I'm glad we
shot this at